matthieu delormeau et benjamin castaldi
sont là ils vont s'affronter lors de
trois épreuves trois vraies épreuves de
koh lanta
alors avant de commencer regardons comme
dans koh lanta le portrait de celui
qu'on appelle benjamin castaldi celui
qu'on a pas une banshee
farage au banjo la mitraille là c'est
bloqué là c'est bloqué tu vois là je
suis là dit attaque mois à les regarder
c'est près de quarante neuf ans et
benjamin animateurs mais aussi
chroniqueur dont diverses démission
médias il est aussi une victime de la
mode
il travaille toujours son look pour être
classé élégant génétiquement c'est une
force de la nature
rien ne l'arrête dans sa vie privée
benjamin aime la boxe
les chiens et les divorces
[Applaudissements]
il est d'ailleurs double champion de
france de pension alimentaire vous
l'avez compris si il sort le grand jeu
il va tout faire péter
[Rires]
des portraits de benjamin alors major
est ce qui vous va si on voit le
portrait très bien sabres ont été très
court merci merci mathieu je vois que
vous le connaissez mieux que nous
michael dolan mathieu qualité matthieu
delormeau mois d'examen aussi votre
portrait avec mon chéri garder au moins
huit chalets ce qui vous va je vous jure
que c'est vrai ce que je dis de tout à
l'heure vous vous avez un tel physique
vous êtes tellement bon qu'il faut que
vous soyez simples dans les tenues et la
voilà là là vous êtes simple là vous
êtes si vous êtes bout des basques est
dégueulasse
vous êtes beaucoup plus beau que
d'habitude oublié parce que je vous ai
vu une couleur bada c'est ce à quoi j'ai
fait des points des pointes à la lime
échappe en partie à leur carte mathieu
45 ans animateur star dans son immeuble
vous ne connaissez sans doute pas ce
grand gaillard de 45 ans pourtant il est
probablement l'idole de votre animal à
quatre pattes
c'est la grande première de aux phoques
cet ancien animateur de ouf et
collectionneur de slips confesse être
très pudique et aimer la sobriété pour
se motiver ceux qui l'auront peut
toujours compter sur l'amour
inconditionnel que son compagnon cyril
lui portent ses forces son savoir vivre
et sa gentillesse qui l'aideront à
s'intégrer facilement aux gros et qui
font de lui un leader naturel
c'est un leader naturel vous avez été
plus régalé que moi j'avance tous les
papas débutants mais là j'ai avec mon
émission et tout ça marchait bien et
puis tu connu international où ça mais
c'est vrai tout ça je vais vous dire la
vérité je fais un king était en espagne
en espagne en espagne et pourquoi ils
m'ont demandé non mais voyez vous
connaissent pas c'est un booking toi à
meudon moi je suis papou qui sait ça à
la fin j'ai pas besoin fait pas de mots
qui lui ferait pas de mots qui me fait
des bouts car il me défonce dedans je
laime alors attention les chiens c'est
notre koh lanta attention le perdant
aura une dernière épreuve dans l'espace
puisqu'il partira dans l'espace grâce à
jamy gourmaud je vous jure que c'est
vrai il fera une vraie expérience dans
l'espace le perdant je vous le jure que
c'est vrai c'est pas une balle alors
bravo c'est un truc de ouf voilà il sera
il sera comme s'ils étaient dans
l'espace qua non non et non plus 2 après
l'arrêt jany gagner qu'elle remédie le
perdant sera dans les bacs gagnez pas
vous n'irez pas dans l'espace mais je
vous le dis l'espace c'est pas du tout
ce que vous croyez c'est plutôt sympa
c'est plutôt sympa mais c'est quand même
une petite terrasse il renonce et voilà
c'est dans l'espace pour n'est pas très
attention la première épreuve aller
simple c'est l'épreuve du tir à l'arc
c'est très simple et chéri vous allez
avoir trois flèches chacun vous allez
tire en même temps dans la cible
chernick à la flèche la plus proche de
l'autre élimine une flèche de son
adversaire vous allez jouer jusqu'à ce
qu'à vocale vous deux néo qu'une flèche
l'un de vous deux n'a plus de fait j'ai
compris ou pas
attention c'est parti erin et mathieu et
benji attention attention là attention
attention attention à toi sine die
lâchez les plantes et quand même elle
est plantée quand même les mena côté
même si l on tient les vaincus pour la
sauce au lait caillé à 0 0 brian est
très bon vous imaginez c'est donc moi la
colle au delà sans déconner regardez là
ils peuvent être appelés les tirs à
gauche mais attention à ligny là la
tendance trop la venue d'un manteau
attention et vous tirez en même temps
maintenant même temps il avant moi
amélie maintenant a tant fait attention
que tu prennes ont alors les flèches les
flèches c'est pas évident on ne pouvait
capter la balle et bah oui mais
attention 3 2
c'est castaldi un poids pour casser les
bras qu'est ce cas oui c'est ça qui l'a
amené lui un petit peu de pommade
benjamin mathieu cécé latine alors vous
voulez pas vous êtes vous arrêter le tir
à l'arc
là il va demander beaucoup voudraient
mais tellement apple la mettais une
serviette
mathieu tu bandes pas c'est une bombe
passée non mais c'est règne la raison
l'a pas possible allez pour l'instant ce
n'est pas grave hein castaldi qui a pris
l'avantagé dans cette première et
produits nomades avant sa mort
évidemment attention c'est parti trois
heures
ah oui d'attenté peut faire mieux selon
m vous allez viens me voir tous les deux
c'est la deuxième épreuve vous vous
mettez devant le bac rouge
benjamin et vous mettez devant le bac
jaune mathieu c'est très simple les
scieries venez venez vous déprime
retenez vous de mener la bd live c'est
très simple et chérie c'est une épreuve
daphné vous allez mettre la tête sous
l'eau celui qui restera le plus
longtemps sous l'eau gagnera la deuxième
épreuve donc exactement si non non non
non puisque la dernière et vous compte
pour 3 bien sûr les familles bah oui bah
oui attention donc au monde cyril ses
douze minutes cinquante deux minutes ça
quoique encore du monde
attention c'est les mecs trois doigts
mettez les trois ans ma fille je sens
bien mathieu sur cette épreuve je le
connais il est très fort en apnée non
moi je parle
3 merci merci pour ce conseil mathieu
t'énerve pas ouais respire bien bébé
preneur allez prenez beaucoup d'air
qu'on prépare les serviettes atout
charme et non les mecs arrête pro vous
souffler après bon sens et toute rancune
n'est pas du tout meiway loin d'êtres
humains est un an atteint un record à
mener non bah oui on va dire qu'on dit
mission sera déjà un très bon en apnée
je peux faire toutes les missions là
dedans moi allez c'est parti
tu dis go alors 3-2 actionné à tort des
deux petits points
oui vous menez pour le tournoi et en
déduit vous venez pour le tournage de
diana jones au plus bas
merci merci madame mais attention trois
deux un peu plus simple
c'est un profond c'est la paix d'oslo
des gens je veux pas que ça triche je
suis je veux pas que ma thuôt regarder
damphousse bien la tête s etc attention
on peut avoir un chrono s'il vous plaît
en régie parce qu'on avait des râteaux
malgré des débuts sans mal benjamin je
ne sens pas mathieu se sont très très
longes combien on regarde combien on n'a
pas seulement 23 secondes
on dirait que ça fait une heure qui sont
dans l'hospitality invité trois abonnés
mais que 30 secondes match c'est bon
c'est bon là je dis là là là ça n'a
jamais été très bon battue je savais que
mathieu était très bon il est très bon
rappeler il a une vraie d'hygiène de vie
championnat je vous retourne à thieu
benjamin donc le grand gagnant de notre
koh-lanta celui qui n'ira pas dans
l'espace ça va se jouer maintenant
c'est une épreuve phare de koh lanta que
nous allons faire maintenant
l'épreuve de la boue bout à bout
shi devant vous regardent et se trouve
une piscine de bon il a fait 23 deux
groupes c'est magnifique j'ai joué une
première
il n'y avait sur elle ses rêves man ma
grand mère elle me défoncer mais qu'est
ce que tu as lu c'est dit c'est dit je
vais rester là tu fumes toi attention il
ne fumait pas allegra regarder ouais ce
que je fais voilà est ce qu'ils fument
nom puis le rêve plus du coup c'est un
format qui seront vains sans maquillage
oh [ __ ] calme toi même toit il est
magnifique
benjamin mon chéri tu sais qu'on t'aime
les chéris vous allez avoir une piscine
de bouc et là vous avez une minute pour
vous couvrir le corps de goût et au m an
maximum dans votre saut n'entre pas dans
votre saut qui est l'avenir un saut
attention à la fin du temps nous allons
peser les sauts celui qui a le son le
plus lourd marquera trois points et sera
le grand gagnant de notre koh lanta est
ce que vous êtes prêt à te donne
autorité à toi et moi c'est garcia donne
moi ça attention non mais d'abord prenez
vos sauts non non non on n'a pas compris
on va vous zéro sauf alstom on voulait
sur soi il faudra bien sûr soi et la
réalité dans le ce a exactement comme un
fort boyard un repli moyen de wes et ça
vient comme à koh lanta mais koh lanta
en fête a aussi comme sur koh lanta
attention c'est parti
3 2
dames 1 attention quoi
voilà
ça va tu es éliminé ses bottes allait
faire plusieurs allers retours oui c'est
de la belgique c'est bien
basi mathieu
pas très haut
mais non
dans les mains d'un tee-shirt où les
bombarder pas
arrêtez de vous battre c'est pas c'est
pas de la boue on va te reste combien de
temps il reste il reste quatre secondes
à lévis douze dernières années autour
huit matches et vite
bajatovic
vite je pense que c'est ma turquie en
tête pour l'instant mais je suis pas sûr
je suis pas sûr ah oui ah non non non
c'est peut-être pas sûr que si on a tué
non là ça va être très très c'est un
combattant sénégalais tout à fait fini
c'est fini les mecs c'est terminé c'est
terminé attention on va d'abord peser le
sceau de benjamin castaldi c'est bon
c'est bon t'as rien mais bravo battu
attention va d'abord posé le sceau de
benjamin castaldi ouaret ya une erreur a
évidemment fait le fils a épousé deux
c'est pas du tout fait pour les mecs par
les normales et bannissez fait pour
bordel de merde et non halal et une
bonne volée reçoit à tort kg 3 kg
attention alors naturel alors barakat al
10 12 12 les 12 kg douce qu il n y
aurait pas mal
pendant ce temps s'inquiète nantes a
déjà fait assez un je pense que tu as
déjà fait assez
tu as déjà face
certains ceux qui leurs calories des
calories les attentions non non attendez
je vais vous le dire retournez vous je
vous dire ok retournez-vous joue
attention retournez vous je vais vous
dire non je veux pas qu'on fiche vais je
vais le dire à protéger spectacle je
veux le voir d'abord moi il faut que je
reprenne ce jeu faut que je repassais
photos affichées non vous avez fait des
anciens de tricherie du fait 12 bat 12
types riche et baptisé puma envie de
citer les noms de 14 kg joly c'est
matthieu delormeau
[Musique]